Data mining is the process of extracting valuable
information from large data sets, patterns,
trends, insights, that you can help to understand
your business better, and there are four stages.
The first of those is setting objectives. This is
where data scientists and business stakeholders
work together to define a business problem that
data mining will be applied too. Step two is
when we take a look at data preparation this is
identifying the data that we need to help answer
these questions and then cleaning that data to
remove any noise such as duplicates missing values
and outliers. Then three, this is the interesting
part this is where we take a look at a number of
algorithms and this is things like clustering
association classification and deep learning
to derive data relationships. And then finally
four brings us to results where we interpret
these results to make sure that they are valid,
novel, useful, and understandable. data mining